It's happening again, another video, oh my god.
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now.
It is Gracevember. Sorry if that's annoying but for those of you that are new, get caught up.
It's the first Tuesday Screwsday of Gracevember, which means I- I just...
It was a name that rhymed with Tuesday, and I didn't fully think through what Tuesday videos would be. In the most broad sense
it's just a day that I screw around. So I decided to create a new YouTube challenge
because a lot of YouTube is fueled by challenges, a very heavily edited version of someone's real life, and
make up? I've created many a dumb challenge here on YouTube.
Will I put it on my face? Mayonnaise, will I put it on my face?
Yes! Balance things on your head that have never been on your head before. Wireless mouse, wireless mirror, a rechargeable vibrator. And this is
no exception. I'm so excited for it. I'm calling this challenge 'One minute to dick it'.
I'm creating a challenge in which you have one minute to draw as many dicks on your face as possible.
And then you challenge other people to do that same thing.
And then you see who can draw the most dicks on their face.
This is important, and this is meaningful, and this is powerful. So far my rules are you can only do the face.
No neck. And you have to- I mean, I don't want to make too many rules. Let's stop talking and let's start dicking around.
I'm gonna set my alarm for one minute. I'm using this black eyeliner that I know I can just pump up if I run out.
The phallic nature of this doesn't stop. Okay, ready, set, one minute to dick it, start. Okay. Oh god.
Okay, I have a mirror here with me too. Ooh...
Boy, did- I mean- you can't...
*groan*
I'm- I don't know what the strategy is. I don't know what the strategy is. The strategy is that there's no judge here.
There's no jury to tell me what's a dick and
what's not a dick, and every dick is probably different so no one can make fun of the way I'm
dicking around here. Oh my god. The mouth wasn't the best place to start, let's go up to the forehead.
Okay, here we go, oh...
Halfway through! Oh no!
This dick's shit.
Oh my eyeliner's running out. Go up, go up. Okay. Okay, here we go. Oh my god,
I'm setting the bar so limp. Nooo!
Go dicks, go dicks, go dicks. I went to college. I'm 32.
How about you? Oh no!
No, turning into hearts!  I don't know what the symbolism is there. Three seconds left. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Oh my god. *timer*
*loud music*
*timer*
*laughs*
Alright, the one-minute to dick it challenge has come to a close for me.
How many dicks did I get? Let's see. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22.
Wow...
I mean, no one that I know has done this before, so we don't know if that's a good or bad
showing, but I do know that I look beautiful, and I do know that my family is proud of me.
I should tag people in the minute to dick it challenge, right? Okay. I'm gonna challenge Liza Koshy.
Maybe she'll do it on her second channel.
I'm gonna challenge Hannah, because she'll just be wholly uncomfortable with this completely.
And I'm also gonna challenge Mamrie, because she'll probably be really good at this. Mamrie's competitive by nature.
But also I just feel like she'll be really good at this. So there you go.
I challenge you three ladies to the minute to dick it challenge.
Thank you guys for watching Tuesday's Screwsday here on It's Grace for the month of Gracevember. I'm making videos Monday through Friday.
Don't forget to subscribe so that you don't miss a single
beautiful piece of art. Click that bell notification,
so you know when I upload, because it's- it varies. And let me know in the comments down below
what kind of videos you want to see for the rest of Gracevember, other than that I don't know.
Let me double check my math. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19,
20, 21, 22. I mean like T-Swift says
*Taylor Swift's 22 plays*
I feel gorgeous.
*Taylor Swift's Gorgeous plays*